our mission in afghanistan continues
we continue to execute a safe orderly
drawdown in accordance with the
president's guidance
for u.s forces to be out of afghanistan
by the end of august
when we fully withdraw the devastation
and and the killings and women
humanitarian crisis fleeing
across the border pakistan president
biden's going to own
these ugly images our vital interests
are isis and al qaeda
and we are going to give them a safe
haven as the taliban takes over
that nation and that vacuum is going to
be filled by terrorists
and i i i'm concerned that we will be
going back
the view from the top republican on
house foreign affairs and from the
pentagon let's bring in our panel former
education secretary bill bennett
harold ford jr former tennessee
congressman and ceo of empowerment and
inclusion capital
and trey gowdy former congressman from
south carolina
gentlemen welcome
bill your thoughts uh on the situation
in afghanistan
u.s troops coming out what are your
concerns
i'll be bipartisan here it's a disaster
it will be on president biden's watch
but
i'm sorry to say president trump is
encouraging it too geopolitically it's
terrible
this is south asia we will have no major
base in south asia
bagram air force base is a substantial
place we
do a lot of monitoring from there and by
the way the belt and road
strategy of china across asia into
europe
goes right through afghanistan we've now
made it a lot easier
plus consider those women what's going
to happen to them are they going to be
able to go to school
and i hope we have gotten out as many
people who helped us
as possible finally not just a moral
victory but in some ways a real victory
for the taliban we cheered when they uh
you know outweighed the soviets
uh the soviets left and we applauded now
we're leaving
admiral kirby's comments from the
pentagon sounded to me an awful lot like
saigon
very sorry to say this but i think this
is a dreadful
and huge mistake there is a lot of
concern about the interpreters the
drivers who have helped us forces over
the past 20 years
here's that concern from a new jersey
democrat let's play the clip
these are interpreters and drivers
people who warned our american troops of
threats
we have got to get them home it is
it is incumbent upon us for our allies
but also for any future
endeavors we have to protect democracy
if our allies can't trust us to have
their backs
like these afghans have had our back for
the
almost 20-year war uh then we are not
going to be able to project our values
our democratic values across the world
herod harold will the bureaucracy get
the friendly afghans out of the country
who have helped us
and your thoughts on the withdrawal from
afghanistan
first of all a happy fourth of july and
happy independence day
i share uh the the frame that
secretary bennett has drawn and and
congresswoman cheryl i think she's right
you have to we as a nation have to show
our commitment to the families to the
individuals and families of those
translators
and intel gatherers we should provide
safe haven if not
even refuge here in the u.s but let's
take a step back for one moment
i think it's hard to argue that we have
not
objectively not done everything we
possibly can to bring
a different security framework to
afghanistan i've traveled afghanistan
several times including
a few times within senator biden and
senator graham and the late senator
mccain
i'm proud of the progress we've made
there but i do think some of the things
that secretary bennett has raised
have to be considered and my senses that
they have
uh and and i hope that the white house
would have not heard from the
administration consistent with what
secretary bennett has raised is whether
or not a red line has been drawn
on the part of this administration
saying if uh
our national security interests are
threatened if the taliban who
again is in some ways a rogue group of
of terrorists and i might
add there were 83 people shot there were
83
week and 13 people we have wrote wrote
crazy
everywhere but if a red line is crossed
and our security interests are
threatening afghanistan
i hope that the administration and
trusted administration will be ready to
go back in they allow the red line to be
crossed
in the past administration under mr
obama the question is will they
will they not allow it this time if the
afghans are threatened
trey gowdy your thoughts
well mike i mean it's the old adage i
mean we're welcome to stop fighting but
that doesn't mean the war is over
and both congressman ford and dr bennett
raised really good points i mean
we need 750 people to protect our
embassy in the airport and you want to
tell me that the country is thriving
and safe for translators and afghan
women i mean 750 soldiers to protect our
embassy
this is my fear and my heartbreak is
explaining to the american sons and
daughters who lost their lives and their
limbs
and part of their their youth in that
country what was it for
what what was it for we have to leave it
there gentlemen
up now hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it
anywhere else